for four years she's served as the
world's top human rights official when
michelle bachelet was appointed in 2018
human rights groups hope the two-time
president of chile herself wants a
political prisoner in her home country
would bring real clout to the role we
need to continue working strongly so
everyone men women and children
are able to live in a life that is safe
peaceful as everybody wants instead
bachelet has faced criticism for not
being forthright on human rights abuses
particularly concerning the persecution
of the uyga community in china a report
she commissioned on the situation near
the start of her term has still not been
published and her visit to china in may
was widely condemned as a whitewash with
the u.s state department calling it a
mistake human rights groups worry that
the un secretary general antonio
guterres who will choose the next human
rights commissioner will again opt for a
candidate who will work largely behind
the scenes rather than very publicly
calling out all abuses
i am deeply concerned that secretary
general guterres is going to completely
undermine the high commissioner's post
make it utterly ineffective by selecting
a quiet diplomat
um now guterres you know stands out in
contrast to some of his predecessors
kofi annan was very outspoken in
speaking about human rights even ban
ki-moon you know not the most outspoken
individual but in the end found his
voice on human rights guterres has been
very reluctant to criticize particular
governments unless they're already
pariahs and i fear that he's going to
choose a high commissioner who's going
to share who's going to share his
reticence about using the only tool the
high commissioner has which is public
reporting and public condemnation
regardless of who the abuser is
diplomats say an official little known
outside the un whose worked for guterres
for decades volker turk is probably the
front-runner for the job two other
candidates the former norwegian prime
minister ernest solberg and kung hwa
kang who is foreign minister of south
korea have higher public profiles but
they're also known to favor quiet
diplomacy over public advocacy
time is running short the next high
commissioner is supposed to be appointed
by the secretary general approved here
in the general assembly and then take up
their post by the 1st of september
leading human rights groups are unhappy
they've offered their input to the
office of the secretary general but so
far they say they've been rebuffed james
bay's al jazeera at the united nations